[Aplausos]
hola qué bueno tenerlos aquí hoy como
para poder compartir de alguna manera
las experiencias de vida que me han
llevado a hoy sentirme muy muy muy feliz
hace 20 años dirijo danza estudio perú
que es una escuela integral de talentos
y esta escuela me ha enseñado a provocar
talento y hoy quiero compartir con
ustedes eso mismo cómo provocar tu
talento todos niños un artista cuando
nace y el problema es cómo seguir
siéndolo cuando crecemos como dijo pablo
picasso porque realmente nosotros cuando
somos chiquititos y tenemos un año 23
estamos bailando nos ponen música
bailamos todos hacemos así y todo no
dice
maravilloso y es verdad es que todos
tenemos talento para bailar no es cierto
o sea nadie puede decir es ciudad que no
tienes talento si haces así y tienes un
talento increíble
pero qué pasa a medida que va pasando el
tiempo es nuestro propio cerebro y
nuestros propios pensamientos los que
van programando nuestra máquina
principal de dirección de todo sin
escuchar las neuronas del corazón y van
cantando nos y tirándonos hacia atrás y
diciéndonos y etiquetando nos que no
somos buenos para esto no somos buenos
para el otro y eso es precisamente lo
que tenemos que aprender a transformar
como conectando contigo mismo entonces
la primera herramienta para provocar tu
talento es conecta contigo porque
vivimos últimamente conectándonos con
todo el mundo y buscando conectar
siempre con alguien más viviendo el
instagram
y diciendo que desgracias a medida están
en europa dios mío yo soy una miserable
inicias el que y es pasa o sea pasa que
vivimos comparándonos con el resto y nos
dejamos de conectar con nosotros mismos
nos dejamos de observar tenemos que
desarrollar a nuestro observador y no
esperar a hacerlo cuando tenemos 55 o 60
años y la vida se nos vino abajo o al
revés
sería ideal como profesores estudiantes
padres madres poder aprender a guiar de
alguna manera a la persona que esté
cerca pero comenzando por nosotros
mismos hacia desarrollar nuestro
observador
que es nuestro observador es mirar nos
comenzamos a mirar a nosotros mismos
quiénes somos qué queremos que no nos
gusta que nos gusta porque a partir de
ahí es que podemos descubrir una
determinada habilidad porque no
solamente podemos tener un talento ya
sea para las matemáticas para el derecho
para la cocina para doblar la ropa y ser
la mejor ama de casa del mundo la mejor
mamá o un talento para amar porque creo
que no todos tienen el talento de amar
bien todos amamos pero a veces amamos
terriblemente y hacemos infelices a todo
el mundo a nuestro alrededor y es
importante poder provocar nuestro
talento y descubrir cuáles pueden ser
esas habilidades el otro día alguien me
pregunta ahí pero yo no sé qué talento
tengo tu talento uno de tus talentos le
dije es amparar le dije porque tú haces
feliz a todo el mundo te alrededor con
esa energía bonita que tienes y siempre
dando tanto amor que yo creo que si uno
de tus talentos es amar bien porque
además con respeto con fe a más bien ese
es un talento y hay gente que se siente
infeliz si no encuentra su talento
entonces hay que comenzar nos a mirar a
nosotros mismos
y tienes talento para la cocina tienes
talento como ingeniero te gustan mal
etcétera crear entonces lo primero que
tenemos que buscar es un lugar para
poder desarrollarlo
entonces estudio he podido ver a muchas
chicas que llegan tímidas y que no saben
que tienen un talento pero es la mamá
las que vio que repente en su cuarto que
salen de la ducha que están desnudos
comienzan a bailar pero frente a la
gente no bailan lineal sin nada entonces
llegan y me dicen ay quisiera por favor
que me ayuden a desarrollar el talento
de mi hija yo le digo en primer lugar
ella quiere le gusta así si le gusta
pero no lo hace delante de la gente
bueno entonces está bien tienes que
contagiarte de ese talento y
definitivamente ir a un lugar donde haya
gente como tú te gusta la cocina anda te
mete clases de cocina investiga por
internet comienza a explorarlo a
desarrollarlo a vivirlo tienes que
sentir tu talento y hacer lo tuyo de una
manera muy particular muy especial no
quiera desarrollar tu habilidad como lo
hace fulano mengano porque ahí pierde su
originalidad y pierdes el enfoque de ti
mismo y pierdes ese observador que es me
miro y comienzo a descubrir quién soy
entonces primero el observador tiene que
estar bien hecho y qué pasa qué pasa si
por ejemplo tienes una mamá o un papá
que vive chanca no se te dice eres muy
malo para esto no sé qué haces
estudiando música no sé qué haces
estudiando ingeniería si tú realmente
debería ser profesor etcétera siempre
vamos a tener a gente que nos tire hacia
abajo y que haga que dudemos de nosotros
mismos pero si tú realmente te has
aprendido a mirar y a conocer muchísimo
más no hay nada ni nadie que te va a
hacer dudar porque tú primero ya sabes
quién eres y nadie va a venir a contarte
quién eres cuando tú ya lo sabes primero
tenemos que comenzar a mirarnos más para
poder conocernos más y parte de tener
eso claro es saber también que nosotros
aparte de ser producto de la genética de
nuestros padres y producto de las
experiencias aprendidas ya sea por
ejemplo los ajenos ejemplos en nuestra
familia etcétera también somos productos
de nuestras propias experiencias y
nuestros errores pero más allá de
nuestra genética y nuestras experiencias
aprendidas de otros ejemplos más los
buenos y lo que hayamos hecho podemos
ser realmente quien nos dé
la gana de ser a partir de que a partir
de que te conozcas primero más comienzas
a decir ok soy así soy un poco déspota
en realidad me ha dado cuenta que estoy
bastante déspota pero no me he querido
mirar no en vez de ver que soy déspota
que estoy tratando mal al resto me estoy
metiendo tanto en el computador que
bloqueó esa realidad no la quiero mirar
porque no me gusta mirar eso de mí y me
distraigo entonces hay mucha gente que
está sin dejar de mirarse y lo que hace
es mirar al resto te vas a una reunión y
todo el mundo está región de todo el
mundo y en realidad todo es normal de
todo el mundo porque no se quiere mirar
primero yo en verdad en mi vida comienza
hablar mal de nadie en mi vida no hacer
que haya alguien que haya dicho algo de
mí tengo que desmentirlo pero si no no
me ocupo de la vida del resto primero me
ocupo de la mía a no ser que sea para
ayudar entonces es muy importante
enfocarse en uno mismo también que eso
sea prioridad en parte tener las
prioridades claras y decir ok primero yo
tengo que estar bien para poder
compartir mi bienestar con alguien más y
a partir de conocerme puedo decidir que
quiero cambiar o transformar de mí mismo
y comenzar a alinearnos porque la base
de la felicidad que definitivamente yo
creo que ayuda muchísimo a ser una
persona más abierta para descubrir mejor
nuestras habilidades es estar alineados
así como el carro que lo tienes que
alinear porque sin alineamiento está
terrible y no anda bien nosotros también
nosotros tenemos somos un conjunto de
cerebro cuerpo emociones tenemos un
corazón que tiene neuronas para los que
no lo saben y por eso hay cierta
conexión siempre entre el corazón y la
razón
y siempre algo que me ha ayudado a estar
mejor en diferentes situaciones es
siempre alinearme conmigo misma yo creo
que es ideal cuando alineamos lo que
pensamos sentimos y hacemos en una misma
línea cuando esa desalineación ese es
hoy no tengo que tengo que comer sano
pero vas y te comes todo el refrigerador
porque no sabes manejar tu ansiedad y
ats líneas te cuando le dices a tu hijo
oye no tomes oye no no te drogues oye no
hace eso no es el otro pero tú lo estás
haciendo delante todo el mundo y llega
la reunión y estás tirado en el piso de
tanto que te tomaste todo lo que
encontraste con qué autoridad vas a
enseñar con el ejemplo se enseña con el
ejemplo igual a un profesor si tú
quieres crear el día de mañana
gente estudiantes exitosos respetuosos
porque creo que es un valor en el perú
que tenemos que desarrollar el respeto
entre nosotros el respeto con lo que
hacemos con los demás el dejar de juzgar
a otros y comenzar a vernos y respetar
la vida de los demás
y cuando tú quieres enseñar con el
respeto primero tienes que respetar no
puede faltar el respeto a un alumno es
decir lo es su vida es valorarlo delante
de todo el mundo porque eso no está bien
ni aquí ni en ningún lado la autoestima
debemos de aprender a querernos más a
entender y aceptar nuestra realidad
ok nuestra realidad es vivo con una mamá
que no me apoya me ha dicho que estoy
donde está este haciendo esto pero yo
realmente creo que si tengo talento para
esto ok si tú crees que tienes talento
por ejemplo para ser tortas de chocolate
pero todo el mundo te está diciendo que
tus tortas son horrorosas y no hay
ninguna persona que te diga que tu torta
está deliciosa definitivamente no tienes
talento para eso y búscate otra
actividad también tienes que ser sincero
y enfrentar la realidad clara de que no
eres buena para eso te gustarán a ti
nomás pero con eso nunca vas a brillar
porque solamente brilla con el talento
de uno el que puede impactar
positivamente con ese talento en su vida
y en la vida de alguien más ya sea 1 2 3
o mucho más personas
entonces sí es importante que el talento
sea reconocido porque a veces uno dice
ya pero yo puedo ser buena estoy no me
importa lo que diga el resto no es el
mensaje que estoy dando si es importante
que tu talento sea valorado porque de
alguna manera te va a dar satisfacción y
vas a sentir que estás en el camino
correcto es por ahí donde tengo que ir
sí sí sí estoy bien ya me dijo que sea
una le gustó mi trabajo por ahí estoy
bien yo siento que estoy bien hazle caso
a tu corazón al descanso a tu cerebro en
línea te dale por ahí con pasión con
optimismo con fe con ganas con
persistencia jk rowling que seguramente
muchos saben quién es escribió el libro
tan exitoso que luego se volvió mil
películas que es harry potter
y mandó su obra del libro harry potter
muy bien envuelta a su primera a la
primera editora a su primer intento y la
editora le respondió muchísimas gracias
pero no estamos buscando una decisión de
esa naturaleza
ok vuelve envolverse un libro y lo
volvió una segunda lo volvió enviar a
una segunda editora le dije no no no
está de acuerdo a la línea que estamos
queriendo lanzar en este momento tercera
editora no muchísimas gracias está bueno
tu trabajo pero no es lo que buscamos
cuarta editora muchísimas gracias no nos
llamen nosotros te llamaremos quinta
editoras ex editora séptima editora y
que pasó en el séptimo intento le
dijeron si nos interesa luz brillo salió
la obra un éxito total qué hubiera
pasado si ella el quinto intento hubiera
dicho no soy muy mala nadie quiere mi
trabajo voy a dejar que la gente
determine quién soy hoy quién quiero ser
no hubiera sido la persona que brilló
como brillo y que nos ha llenado a la
vida de un entretenimiento genial porque
es lindo ir a ver esa película y
disfrutarla morir para los que les
gusten los que no también es una gran
obra entonces es importante saber quién
eres y a partir de conocerte mucho más y
aceptarte con tus errores y tus virtudes
también dejar de lado el exceso de
autocrítica que es un error de muchos es
un error de muchos porque así como decía
que vivimos criticando al resto nos
criticamos demasiado a nosotros mismos
se ha puesto a pensar qué pasa cuando
cometes un error como esto es un error y
dices novio error que brusca que
estúpido dios mío soy un y encima
tienes un amigo que te diga que te dice
eres de lo peor no sirves para nada
estás hecho no y digas que te echan que
ni tú estás chancado y caminas así y te
chancaní sebastián cuando se y te echan
que ni te vas haciendo más chiquitito y
termina bien chancado una semana
deprimida en tu cuarto deprimida
no no tenemos que dejar que nadie tenga
el poder de hacernos sentir bien o mal
porque nosotros no podemos controlarlo
todo pero si podemos controlar el como
lo demás nos afecte y tenemos que dejar
de victimizarnos también quién eres tú
eres una persona feliz con momentos
tristes o eres una persona triste con
momentos felices te has puesto a pensar
en eso tú cómo te consideras una persona
feliz con momentos tristes o una persona
triste con momentos felices viajado
cuenta de la pregunta
feliz con momentos tristes y es que
todos tenemos emociones podemos sentir
tristeza frustración ira
todo tipo de emociones y esas emociones
no se van de la noche a la mañana y si
se van por un momento van a volver a
venir siempre y tenemos que aprender a
sortear la vida como viene con todo eso
porque eso es parte también de saber
encontrar el día de mañana nuestras
habilidades en sacarnos a nosotros
mismos y no es buena idea
desestimar una emoción y decir es una
mala emoción no no no no no como decide
feliz feliz yo estoy feliz pero en
realidad está súper triste y lo que
haces es abrir la refrigeradora porque
estás lleno de ansiedad y comerte todo
antes de dormir
porque como no sabes manejar tu ansiedad
bloquea esta emoción no la enfrentas no
te enfrentas a ti mismo y lo que haces
es hacer algo negativo contigo o te vas
te drogas te tomas todo el fin de semana
todo lo que encontraste no es cierto
zurrón citó con cocacola y entonces así
todos están hasta el queque y no sientes
tristeza ni irán y furia de la realidad
que tienes que enfrentar para poder
comenzar a manejar
entonces la autocrítica no se
autocrítica en tanto acepten que no
somos perfectos y que nada en la vida lo
va a hacer y que vas a tener que aceptar
que vas a tener que comenzar a enfrentar
tus emociones en vez de llenarte de mil
pastillas o de exceso de comida hay
otras maneras de lidiar con nuestras
emociones hay otras maneras de
enfrentarlas y de tomar las riendas y
decir lo que yo enfrento voy a sentir la
tristeza si me voy a echar un rato a
llorar un día dos días una semana pero
después después me paro después me paro
me secó las lágrimas y digo me llamo acá
hay un secreto que les voy a contar que
yo siempre hago es algo muy personal que
voy a compartir con ustedes hoy y si les
parezco una loca no me importa porque yo
me amo me adoro y me ha servido mucho sí
decir de usted es genial y es que por
ejemplo desde que era muy chica y eso
desde los 9 años a que compuse mi
primera canción
mi primera canción se llamó sola si se
las cantó se mueren
estaba sola aburrida y ese aburrimiento
me provocó mi creatividad yo jugaba con
mi barrio y sola tenía un parque
maravilloso salía corría vaca pero
estando sola compuse esta canción me
encuentro aquí y estoy sola y así venía
la canción hacia las canto a todas
porque nos quedamos 30 horas aquí
esa parte de mí que me gustaba enfrentar
mi soledad me hizo darme cuenta que yo
en mi soledad me encontraba me
encontraba con mis talentos y siempre
podía crear por eso me gusta estar sola
a veces siento que soy el peor día
porque me recargo de la energía de los
demás y de la gente pero también me
gustan mis momentos solos aprendamos a
disfrutar de nuestra soledad de no
llenarnos intenta gente para distraernos
no te distraigas de quién eres tú
y este secreto consiste en el siguiente
yo siempre me queda chica cuando me
pasaba algo terrible por ejemplo terminé
con mi enamorado una amiga me decepcionó
me sentía al sol etcétera con la cara
hinchada de haber llorado mi mirada
después de haber llorado porque tenía
que llorar bien yo dramática olvidaré
esa frase que dice yo no hago yo no
dramas yo un circo de soleil porque soy
artista esa medida regia regia total la
carencia y se me pasaba la tontería me
venía la luz porque mi cerebro comenzaba
a controlar las emociones gracias a dios
porque también tiene lo este derecho
izquierdo ahí creo que me dio equilibrio
y me mira al espejo y hablaba conmigo
misma qué es lo que hace mucha gente en
el psicólogo que me parece genial ir al
psicólogo me parece genial tener un
coach que si no es el día de mañana tu
mamá tu tía tu hermana tu amiga que te
sabe dar consejos puede ser un psicólogo
genial que te escuche pero es lo que es
lo que hacen realmente los psicólogos
finalmente es que tú hables puedas
expresarte con alguien que de repente no
te conoce mucho ni te va a juzgar ni te
va a hacer sentir juzgado si tú expreses
lo que sientes y órdenes sus ideas de
tal manera que comienzas a responderte
solo o sola
y eso es genial entonces yo lo que hacía
era desarrollarlo primero con mi madre
que cuando ya el colegio le contaba a
todos mis problemas en el senado siempre
es bueno tener a alguien con quien te
desahogas y no es el psicólogo alguien
más me llama esa persona se queda dos
horas y me pasa la comida de cachete en
cachete y terminaba de comer le voy a
contar mi vida entera y me sentía mucho
mejor mi mamá se había quedado 30 horas
ahí diciendo cómo me he visto pero yo me
sentía mejor cuando no la tenía yo me
enfrentaba a mí me secaba las lágrimas
me miraba al espejo y hablaba como si
decido que difiero la que has hecho mal
acá de qué manera ese impactado tú en
esto que acaba de vivir porque te parece
controlado te saco la vuelta qué pasó
qué hiciste tú que no hiciste tú que
hizo el que no hizo él etcétera ok de
ahora en adelante cómo hacer las cosas
que vas a hacer entonces comenzaba a
programar mi cerebro porque así como no
vídeo es donde te hablan de la
programación etcétera
tú puedes programar tu cerebro también
escuchándote escuchándote aquí
escuchándote aquí alineando te puedes
programar quien quiere ser de ahora en
adelante si quieres ser más humilde
puedes serlo si quieres ser una persona
más sonriente comienza a sonreír más
vicente con una sonrisa si quien quiere
hacer hoy
entonces yo me miraba hablaba conmigo
misma sacaba conclusiones interesantes
para aprender de mi experiencia la
enfrentaba así con la cara todo hinchada
y decido que de ahora en adelante cómo
va a ser y eso me da una esperanza me
daba la esperanza de una posibilidad de
que mañana todo podría ser mejor de que
mi vida era de hoy en adelante y que los
errores ya habían quedado atrás
y eso me ha ayudado para que para ser
más segura de sí misma y entonces cuando
yo me sentía más segura a mí misma me
sentía mejor para salir en el colegio en
los juegos florales en el concurso de
talentos a cantar la canción que me
diera la gana sin música y hacerlos roig
de mi vida pero si yo no hubiera tenido
esta terapia conmigo misma que yo mismo
me practicaba saca mis conclusiones me
analizaba me secaba la cara y saben lo
que hacía el último punto de mi
experiencia me miraba y sonreía mirando
en el espejo y apagaba la luz siempre
con una sonrisa de mí misma pero no con
cualquier sonrisa ah no yo apagada lo
estaba sonriendo y si la sonrisa no me
gustaba otra vez aprendí a la luz al
ofrecer la loca más loca del mundo pero
no importa hasta que mis ojos no
brillaban con mi sonrisa bien hecha yo
no pago la luz y eso lo hago bastantes
veces bastante seguido lo hacía todos
los días antes ahora lo hago un poquito
menos pero lo hago cuando lo necesito y
me va bien y siempre pago la luz con una
sonrisa porque porque me gusta ver la
mejor imagen que puedo tener de mí misma
me gusta quererme y llamarme con todos
mis defectos con mis mil manchas
etcétera hace un tiempito tuve un
accidente
me caí de cara literalmente hace un
tiempo hace unos años de cara porque
corría hacía mucho atletismo
me caí y se me rompió el ojo acá era un
monstruo se me respeto a la cara se me
abrieron los labios me de forma íntegra
yo solamente recordaba que en la
ambulancia decía dios mío como no se
retrocede el tiempo para que no me he
pasado esto
es así se me abrió la rodilla de acá que
mi rodilla con la que corría morir y
participar en mis carreras porque yo
aparte de ser bailarín artista me gusta
componer y he podido tener la suerte de
desarrollar todos mis talentos por todo
esto que les estoy contando porque hoy
por hoy puedo componer canciones ya no
para hacer la artista que era cantando
frente a miles de personas en un
concierto sino para poder compartirlo
con chicas que en la escuela quieren ser
artistas entonces compongo canciones las
llevó al estudio grabó lo compartí soy
feliz así corría y desarrollado otros
talentos que me hacían sentir contenta
en ese momento dije como no se retrocede
el tiempo pero aprendí aprendí esa
experiencia también y es que tenemos que
aprender de las experiencias y también
es importante tener a alguien que nos
inspiren la vida del otro día conversaba
también con un amigo
y su papá había sido alcohólico y yo
creo que esa es la realidad de muchos
muchos tenemos a veces alguien en la
familia que tiene ese problema y yo le
dije quién es la persona que te ha
ayudado a ser la persona exitosa que
eres porque este chico es un hombre
extraordinario es un hombre que empleo
aplauso existencia y es uno